the mask wars are raging again president
trump is making cinematic videos taking
his mask
off bill de blasio and joe biden are
filming dramatic scenes putting their
masks
on and california is mandating masks in
between
sips and bites at lunch i kid you not
liberals don't seem to understand why
the masks have to be political why do
they have to be political
they ask that's because these highly
political people don't seem to
understand what politics is
and that's why they're messing up the
politics all the way looking through
november
i'm michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from yesterday is from kyle
the only thing more dangerous than kovid
19 is biden 20.
wow that is good that is pithy and
absolutely
correct the mask wars are back the mask
wars are back and everyone thinks we're
all fighting about science but we're not
fighting about science we're fighting
about
politics president trump you may have
seen it when he
beat the china virus in three days and
using only the power of mcdonald's
french fries and his pure coffee
president trump flies back to the white
house and films this cinematic video
where he gets back he gets off the
helicopter he walks up to the portico
and he takes the mask off
so this could be a movie trailer for a
michael bay movie i mean this is
pretty pretty well shot pretty
intense high budget high energy
marine walks off the president walks off
notice by the way everyone's still
wearing masks at this point when they're
all close to each other
gets up to that portico huge
shot from beneath and then the mask is
off he salutes
[Music]
there's a lot to this message i know i
mean we're kind of joking that it's like
some
giant 200 million michael bay movie or
something but
there is a lot to this message which is
the president is willing to take
prudent steps if he's got this virus and
he's next to a marine
but then when he's out there in the open
on the portico he's going to take it off
he's not going to live in fear of this
thing when there's no reason to
bill de blasio filmed a response video
to this seriously like a teenager on
youtube filming a response video
he steps outside of gracie mansion i
take it or outside of city hall
and he walks over to his portico and he
puts his mask on
holding up the mask for everybody to see
[Music]
then he puts it on it's kind of a funny
idea it's just a lame
performance then he salutes
the people then he walks back inside
[Music]
so this is one mistake the left makes
generally which is that trump sets the
conversation and then everyone reacts to
it
it's kind of a funny idea right if you
if you have this political disagreement
again notice i'm saying not a scientific
disagreement
a political disagreement about the masks
trump says we sh
the mask is a symbol you shouldn't be
afraid of the virus
you shouldn't live your life cowering in
fear and then the left saying you should
be very very afraid stay in your
apartment don't go anywhere
if you have that political disagreement
it's kind of funny to post that response
video except that
trump is setting the tone right so
everything he's just
shot for shot he's just performing the
the trump scene same thing with joe
biden joe biden
has a side by side he posts it to
twitter trump on the left biden on the
right even that
even that as a matter of stagecraft very
stupid for the left
because the left side of the screen is
the stronger side of the screen
it's the same reason that stage right so
when you're in the audience the people
who are on the left
is the stronger side of the stage we
read left to right and he puts trump on
the left and he puts biden on the right
and trump is taking the mask off
biden is putting the mask on in
california they've taken this
to the craziest extreme they posted a
psa
from the office of the governor of
california saying
going out to eat with members of your
household this weekend don't forget to
keep your mask on
in between bites do your part to keep
those around you healthy
slow the spread that sounds like a great
way to get marinara
sauce all over your mask i have this
idea of you're you go out to an italian
restaurant you go you get your spaghetti
and meatballs you know you've got your
mask on then you lower your mask a
little
you slurp up the spaghetti and meatballs
the sauce going everywhere you've got
this filthy mask but that that will keep
you safe
obviously at this point they are just
trolling us nobody seriously thinks
that you should have your bite of pasta
and you kind of
lower the mask you put it in and you
pick it back up touching your face the
whole time
nobody nobody seriously believes that
and obviously gavin newsom
not a scientist not a medical expert
he is a politician and this disagreement
is a political one
no one seems to want to talk about that
and no one even seems to
understand what we're talking about
because they say it's about public
health
the phrase public health means
health from a political perspective
public the word
public means political what is politics
politics is how we all live together
that's
that's what it means it comes from the
word polis like the greek city-states
how do we all get along together the
reason the left doesn't understand this
the reason that the left
is now censoring conservatives whenever
we make any point on this
is because the left the progressive left
has succeeded
at making everything political the shoes
i wear the coffee i drink
every single thing is political except
for politics
except for genuinely political decisions
such as
how we're allowed to go eat at
restaurants how we're allowed to walk
about in society
how we're allowed to interact with one
another those are the most political
decisions
that there possibly can be by definition
that has been taken away from the people
that
we're no longer allowed to talk about
that has been given to so-called experts
who maybe they know a thing or two about
some particular field of medical science
but they don't know
a damn thing about politics and that is
what the problem is
we are actually talking past each other
right now
cnn typified this so beautifully
just yesterday it really makes you think
it really makes you think that people
have are simply not
literate anymore so we don't even know
what we're talking about but if you want
to think a lot better and be more
literate you've got to check out thinkor
thinker.org they summarize the key ideas
from new and noteworthy nonfiction
giving you access to an entire library
of great books in bite-sized form
you can read or listen to hundreds of
titles in a matter of minutes
you got old classics like dale carney's
had to win friends and influence people
you've got recent bestsellers like
jordan peterson's 12 rules for life
thinker offers a large variety of titles
across a ton of categories they've got
current affairs politics
business education history relationships
they got they have everything
they've they've got our very own ben
shapiro's right side of history they've
got matt walsh's the unholy trinity
what about do they have reasons to vote
for democrats i hope they do i hope
they do i love it you've heard about
thinker on my prageru show the book club
we love these guys if you want to
challenge your preconceptions if you
want to expand your horizons
most importantly of all if you want to
sound smart at cocktail parties go to
thinker.org t-h-i-n-k-r
no e no time for that dot org start a
free trial download the app today
let them know that you heard about it on
the michael knowles show
that is thinker t-h-i-n-k-r no e no time
for that thinker.org
this is a political issue there is a
scientific component too i'm not even
talking about that i don't even care
about that really
i'm just talking about the politics
because that's the only one that people
don't seem to understand
caitlyn collins over at cnn was furious
just like de blasio was just like biden
was the trump took his mask off
she tweets out only days into his
diagnosis the first thing president
trump does when he gets back to the
white house
is take his mask off oh how angry she is
except
except for this in the white house
briefing room remember now everyone's
super nervous about kovid she's in the
white house briefing room the cameras
she thinks
are off they're not really off but she
thinks they're off
there's still a bunch of people in the
white house briefing room she steps up
takes her mask off
the white house staff leave still a ton
of reporters in there caitlyn collins
stands up
get ready for the next she takes the
mask off there it is it's off
it's gone she's upset when trump does it
it's not upset when she does it
she probably wasn't even thinking about
it in her defense it's not like some
nefarious thing
it's because this has become so
political it's become so political now
that in that trump video he's not saying
don't wear a mask
ever he's saying don't make people feel
comfortable ever he does he's not even
saying that
he's wearing a masking part of the video
and then when he is alone
so far away from everybody on the white
house portico outside he takes the mask
off they're saying you're not allowed to
do that even outside
people when you walk around in
california outside they will scowl at
you if you don't have a mascot
but the medical experts don't seem to
have a problem with walking around
outside with a mask
off the president of the italian society
of anti-infection therapy said on
tuesday that italy's new
political decision policy
to mandate outdoor mask wearing is a
mistake dr matteo bassetti
who is the director of infectious
diseases at san martino hospital in
genoa
he said that the prime minister the
prime minister's decision the political
decision
to impose outdoor masks has no basis in
science he says the use of masks only
makes sense in confined spaces where
it's not possible to have certainty
and guarantee of the necessary physical
distancing or outdoors when you cannot
maintain physical distancing
i have tried to look for scientific
evidence on the use of outdoor masks and
their potential benefits for
transmission of virus
but could find none no matter
this is a political
symbol it is there's no use in
complaining about that
when the liberals say gosh i just don't
understand why this has to be political
what they're really saying is gosh i
don't understand why
everyone doesn't agree with my politics
that's what it is
and i'm using liberal liberally here you
know they're obviously left-wing
liberals but there are some right-wing
liberals too
kind of more libertarian types though
interestingly on the masks the
libertarians are very anti-mask
but that's that's sort of another
political issue
but i'm talking about the kind of
squishy republicans who say oh gosh come
on it doesn't need to be a political
issue
that's because they've accepted many
premises of liberalism okay which is
fine i guess that's their prerogative
but they at least ought to understand
that politics is bigger than that
politics is
what we do in public you know
the the radicals of the 1960s
had a slogan that talked about how they
were going to obliterate
this distinction here they said the
personal is the political
another version of that is that the
private is the public
public and political mean the same thing
the personal is the political what does
that mean what that means is
that every decision that we make is
now a political decision how you relate
to your husband that's totally political
how you relate to your kids totally
political
but the irony of this was that more and
more and more
actual political decisions were taken
away and they were given to experts they
were given to bureaucrats they were
given to the administrative state they
were given to the deep state that's
all all terms for the same thing woodrow
wilson
planned on this mack daddy of left-wing
progressivism in america
he planned it out he wrote it all out he
said that we now live in this age
of charles darwin this age of evolution
this age of perfecting society
and so we've got to listen to the
scientific experts
and we can't let these these stupid
people these these ruffians
go out there and screw up our sign so
we're going to give all the real
political decisions
to these bureaucrat technocrat data
scientists the medical geniuses
and then we're going to have them all
fight over a bunch of stupid nonsense
like coffee and sneakers and tv shows
and
things like that and so far it's worked
very well
but there is an alternative the question
of should we wear masks outside
maybe has a scientific component to it
although that
italian epidemiologist says there's no
scientific reason to wear masks outside
but it might it has a scientific
question to it but it has a political
question which is
if i found out tomorrow i'm just purely
hypothetical if i found out tomorrow
that us all wearing masks all the time
outside
would extend our life by five years on
average
and not wearing masks outside would
decrease our life by five years
on average i would still not want to
wear masks
outside why because that's not the
society i want to live in
you know as breath is a symbol of our
life
okay you see it all throughout the bible
you see it all throughout literature
if we are now not allowed to see each
other smile
if we are now not allowed to communicate
with each other without it being muffled
if we are now not allowed to see each
other's beautiful faces if we are now
not allowed to get the sunshine on our
face
if we're not allowed to get a smile
that's worth five years to me
that total of course it is now the
premise here for the secular leftists
the liberals
is they say that all that life's about
is extending the time you're on this
earth
as long as possible for conservatives we
don't believe that
we think look okay maybe you live 80
years maybe you live 85 years i mean
i want to live as long as i can but this
isn't it there's more to life than just
existing right now we know as from a
public health perspective
we know if we if we banned automobiles
we would save how many people per year
tens and tens of thousands of people per
year would be saved if we banned
automobiles
that is a public health decision so are
we going to do it
i don't think so why not because you
don't care about human life i guess
you're not pro-life huh
no it's because we're willing to accept
some risk in society
we'd rather live in a society that has
automobiles than in a society that does
not have automobiles
but that's a public health decision this
is what they try to do on guns
they say guns are a public health
decision guns kill however many people
per year so we've got to ban the guns
and then
look this is not politics why does this
have to be political just guns
because we're talking about how it
relates to the public so that is
political
and i don't care how many times dr fauci
insists that he gets to run our country
for us
he doesn't that's not our constitutional
system
it has been perverted more and more into
a system like that
but i ain't having it politics is not a
dirty word
the the right sometimes plays into this
is we say oh we want to de-politicize
everything
yeah i want to de-politicize i want to
make
less a matter of partisanship matters of
our private lives
but i want more politics i want an
actual authentic politics
where we can discuss the issues and not
just pretend that there's only one
answer to everything and coincidentally
that answer happens to be the liberal
answer
there's we're talking about safety all
the time there's different kinds of
safety
there's the safety about when we go out
in public there's the safety
of when you go on the internet when you
go on the internet you need life lock
because
identity fraud is very very real
synthetic identity fraud is one of the
fastest growing financial crimes
in the united states it happens when
criminals use a combination of fake and
real information
to create an entirely new identity they
combine real personally identifiable
information such as your social security
number
with a fake name and a fake address to
open bank accounts seek credit
even obtain health insurance seriously
monitoring your credit
is not enough you could miss certain
threats
luckily there's life lock lifelock
detects a wide range of identity threats
like your social security
number for sale on the dark web no one
can prevent all identity theft
or monitor all transactions at all
businesses but you can find out if your
information is on the dark web
get your free dark web scan at
lifelock.com
scan very easy s-c-a-n
pick the plan that's right for you save
up to 25
off the first year with promo code
knowles k-n-w-l-e-s you got to remember
two things scan and nulls
but don't scan nulls don't scam nulls
either that's a free scan at
lifelock.com
scan 25 off with promo code knowles go
do it right now
the problem here is that under the guise
of non-political politics the radical
leftists are
remaking all of our political decisions
facebook
just yesterday censored a post from
president trump
some radical left oligarchs in silicon
valley are censoring the duly elected
president
they did that because he compared the
coronavirus to the flu
and he said that america should learn to
live with the illnesses because the
illnesses are here to stay
they censored him for making a
comparison
he didn't say the flu is the coronavirus
he didn't say
that they are exactly the same he didn't
really say anything that was of a
particularly
medical nature he made a comparison
and the left says you can't you're not
allowed to make that comparison anymore
that is not scientific fact checking
that
is political censorship flu season is
coming up writes the president
many people every year sometimes over a
hundred thousand and despite the vaccine
die from the flu that's true that's very
true
are we going to disclose are we going to
close down our country no we have to
learn to live with it just like we are
learning to live with covet
in most populations it's far less lethal
also true not saying in the entire
population it's far less lethal
saying that in most populations for very
old people or the immune compromised
it's more lethal
but for young people for babies for
instance
for less lethal facebook's covet-19
misinformation policies which march
saw introduced into the company say they
will
remove misinformation about the
coronavirus when it could contribute to
imminent
physical harm what misinformation did
you see in president trump's comment
facebook spokesman says her name is liz
bourgeois
what a name what a what an apt name
liz bourgeois she says we remove
incorrect information about the severity
of covid19 and have now removed this
post
there was no incorrect information here
what did he say about the severity of
covet 19
he says covid in most populations is
less lethal than the flu that's
obviously true all the data back that up
not in most national populations in most
populations within a country is what
he's saying
obviously true that's all he said about
kovitt the rest he said about the flu he
said flu season's coming up true
many people every year get the flu true
sometimes it's over a hundred thousand
true
despite the vaccine people die from the
flu very true
are we going to learn are we going to
close down our country that's a
political question you see what are you
going to fact check politics now
now we've learned to live with it just
like we're learning to live with kovid
true it's all true it's all true
no matter facebook's going to take it
down that is too far that is too much
you want you talk about in authentic
politics
we now have a company that largely
controls the flow of information around
the internet they are now
censoring the president of the united
states
for no reason whatsoever
that is absolutely unacceptable
the government needs to go after
facebook with everything they've got
which i believe the doj is already doing
we cannot tolerate that
you see now everything we're all arguing
about the politics of
some brand we're all arguing over the
politics of our relationship to our
teacher our friends or our family
but we're told we're not allowed to
discuss the politics
of a private company censoring the duly
elected president
a private company which largely controls
the flow of information around the
internet
i want to lose the stupid personal
politics i want to regain the actual
important public politics any political
ideology
that tells you it's fine for some
silicon valley oligarch to censor the
president of the united states
is an incorrect political view i'm
afraid it's an insufficient one it's
made
some mistakes silicon valley by the way
unless you think there's some balance
out there there isn't
a new report from wired magazine says
that almost 95 percent of
political donations from employees at
silicon valley companies
we talked about all the big ones you
know google facebook twitter all the
apple
95 go to joe biden donations to joe
biden
from these employees of big tech
companies have been
double those that went to hillary
clinton in 2016.
all of those companies wired reports
that these these tech
firms employees have contributed 20
times as much money to biden
as to trump since the start of 2019.
so these guys are pretending to be
impartial they're saying look we're just
independent fact checkers
totally independent but also we're all
democrats we all donate to democrats
and we're going to censor the president
for nothing for nothing for saying
things that are true
that we don't like and we're going to
pretend it's not political
big tech employees are not the only
partisan democrats right now
pretending to be non-partisan did you
watch joe biden's town hall the other
night probably not
who would have so this was on nbc
and it was a town hall with undecided
voters
now the the undecided voters come out
and they ask these softball questions to
biden
and this is supposed to be a nice fair
non-partisan event right
the trouble is some of those undecided
voters looked familiar
some people at the washington free
beacon went through some of the previous
town halls
some of the previous news clips found
out that those undecided voters
previously
had identified themselves as joe biden
voters so it opens up
on october 5th just yesterday two days
ago welcome back
welcome back miami and the town hall
meeting with former vice president joe
biden taking questions from undecided
voters
peter gonzalez has next question welcome
to miami mr vice president
um i was born in hartford connecticut
and i've been living in coral gables for
the last
20 plus years we get four more years of
treatment
august 21st he says he's voting for the
future attracting
younger voters who voted for hillary
clinton
four years ago but has voted republican
in the past what's your question for mr
biden
mr vice president things uh you know
that that joe biden said during his
speech that resonates same guy says he's
voting for biden october 21st what
defines america's possibility
matteo gomez joins us now uh first-time
voter came to the us from colombia at
age two welcome
spent a lot of october thank you lester
for the introduction
after watching the debate matteo gomez
told us he really didn't
and it really did not do a lot to help
him if you had to
pull the trigger and vote for someone
tomorrow
how would you vote september 30th he's
going to vote for bud
it wouldn't be there
just how unpresidential the whole entire
debate was
so we've now got three allegedly
undecided voters on nbc
who are all self-described
joe biden voters so it's a it's a farce
it's not real
it's a show it is a
total performance of lies
that could be the subtitle of the
election
they're all they're all pretending look
we're not really political
i love this one my friend my it's always
my liberal friends who tell me this
they say you know look i'm not really
political me look i'm
i'm kind of a moderate actually i just
think we should have abortion on demand
i think that experts should make all of
our political decisions i think we need
socialist health care
i think we need to raise taxes on the
rich and i think we need open borders
look i'm not political
that's just common sense this is what
they do when they say they're going to
take away guns usually for public health
right they pretend it's not political
they say look
i'm not trying to get into politics i'm
not trying to
i'm not trying to get rid of your second
amendment or whatever that thing is you
like i'm just
i'm just talking about common sense gun
reform just common sense
and i'm sure by the way that their views
are common sense
if you are a liberal who believes that
liberalism is the only
political view that it is legitimate to
hold
but for the rest of us who are not
liberals then we look at it and we say
uh no that's not common sense
actually seems very nonsensical
now there is good news here though
because as the left puts on this
performance
about the lack of politics the
non-partisan people the people who are
independent
for the actual undecided voters trump is
doing
great for the actual undecided voters
issue by issue everything stacks against
joe biden new study was released last
week
that showed 66 to 70 percent
of likely voters in five battleground
states support
school choice publicly funded school
choice
school choice is a huge winning issue
for republicans we should talk about it
all the time
because joe biden totally opposes it
donald trump
totally supports it this is from the
manhattan institute which commissioned
in this survey
added it on to a poll from rasmussen
this was conducted in pennsylvania
ohio wisconsin michigan north carolina
all these battleground states
joe biden has a very very negative view
of school choice and so the point is
if i'm president betsy devos's whole
notion from charter schools to this are
gone
all gone i actually asked secretary
devos about this when she came on the
verdict podcast
with um with me and senator cruz you can
check out that episode as well
now why are democrats doing this it's so
unpopular
they're doing this because they're in
bed with the teachers unions the
teachers unions
are part of their constituency they in
some
in some parts own the democratic party
so they're not allowed to support school
choice even though seventy percent of
people support
trump and the republicans should run
hard on this there's another big issue
too
there's another big issue that the
republicans and trump in particular ran
on in 2016.
and he hasn't talked about it as much in
2020 but it's a huge
winning issue and the democrats are
completely
wrong on it it is not working at all it
does involve
security it does involve protection
and when you want to protect your car
you've got to turn to car shield okay
i know that with car shield i don't
worry about any sort of
problems with my car why car shield
offers
a wide range of protection plans that
can save you
thousands of dollars for a covered
repair that means that that when that
check engine light comes on
it is a lot less scary than it used to
be
you have the freedom to choose your
favorite mechanic you get the freedom to
choose your favorite dealership to do
the work and car shield gets the rest
taken care of it's not just that you've
got to use their one guy who's out in
the middle of belugaville
even if your car breaks down while
you're traveling the choice of a repair
shop is still
up to you and on top of that there is no
long-term contract or commitment
payments are flexible car shield plans
are customizable to your exact
needs they've helped over one million
drivers that's why they are america's
number one auto protection company
i highly recommend this especially as
someone whose car has broken down a
number of times
i used to dread it used to dread the car
repairs now with car shield
i have peace of mind get coverage today
see why car shield cars
go farther call 800-665-2157
mention code knowles or visit
carshield.com and use codenoles
to save 10 that is carshield.com code
knowles
and a deductible may apply all right
tonight we've got the vice presidential
debate between pence and harris the
daily wires very on matt walsh we'll be
live reacting to it in all access join
him tonight at 8 45 eastern
5 45 pacific head on over to
dailywire.com if you are not
a daily wire member already join all
access today 20 off with code
debate you can watch it all live head
over to dailywire.com
we'll be right back with a lot more
welcome back school choice big winner
among the undecided voters but then
there's another big
winner and the left they want to pretend
that people are on their side with this
issue but they're not that issue is
immigration washington post just comes
out they say trump's refugee
ceiling is bad for everyone but bigots
here we go deplorable irredeemable dregs
of society that's what you are
if you oppose taking in more and more
immigrants into this country now
what president trump has said is that
he's going to reduce the number of
immigrants who come into the country not
by a lot
just by very little he said as a matter
of
the refugee policy in the new fiscal
year
15 000 refugees will come into the
country 15 000 seems pretty nice
now before that under the obama
administration you saw a cap at about 96
000 but why would we be taking in all of
these refugees
when there has been relative peace all
around the globe
we've been pulling out of these wars one
of the arguments for taking in refugees
is look we're involved in these wars
and because of that we have a
responsibility to these local
populations so we're going to take them
in whether or not you agree with that
argument
that was the argument now we're saying
okay we're still going to take in
fifteen thousand we're just not gonna
take in
i don't know a hundred thousand america
takes in more immigrants
legal as well as illegal than any
country on earth
by a long shot we're talking about like
2 million per year
the last 60 years has been the largest
migration
from one place to another or from
multiple places to another
in the history of civilization
we've never seen a larger migration than
we have into the united states
over the past 60 years and people
justifiably
think maybe that's a little bit too much
not because we don't like people around
the world but just because
it's very difficult to assimilate that
many people
we have the largest foreign born
percentage of the population that we've
had since the 1890s
and at this time we're being told we
have to discourage assimilation
well if you don't have a common culture
if you don't have a common language
if you don't have common practices then
you don't have a country
right then you don't have a common
country and that's what we're seeing
coming apart at the seams it's not
really the immigrant's fault necessarily
it's the the policies
and the people who are using immigration
policy to try
to further weaken the country because
they think the country is rotten and
evil and no good
such as the people who support for
instance the 1619 project view of
america
or the people who believe that america
is hopelessly bigoted or the people who
want to destroy our system of law and
order
any of those people most americans
though
want to reduce immigration levels there
was a survey came out a couple years ago
that showed that americans want to
reduce
immigration dramatically by
60 percent or so and this is a majority
of americans who want to do it
not just republicans it cuts into
democrats as well
that's a big winner we were told when
trump came down that escalator in 2015
remember
we were told this guy there's no way
this guy's going to win
he just said that that illegal
immigration might not be a great thing
he called illegal immigrants criminals
and rapists and murderers
there's no way he's never going to win a
hispanic vote and
he's certainly never going to win and
what was so funny is you had a lot of
hispanic voters saying like yep yeah
that's true
those drug cartels man they're pretty
bad they cross the border a whole lot
we don't like them we're very against
them
of course because people all agree with
it not all of them but most people agree
with this
but political correctness means they're
not allowed to say it out loud so that
when someone comes in
such as a trump and says what they're
thinking they might criticize him in
public
but they will vote for him that's a
great issue for republicans
school choice abortion both going in our
favor or school choice rather
immigration both going in our favor
abortion actually though is as well
and joe biden has now gone completely
out in the open on abortion
there used to be a view among the
allegedly devout catholics in this
country
who supported abortion they obviously
weren't particularly devout catholics
but
they would support abortion
and they would justify it to themselves
and to the public by saying look i am
personally very against killing all
these babies
but politically it is a right it's a
constitutional right
you can see it right there in the
constitutional text right below the
penumbras and right above the emanations
now you got it's an invisible link
but you can see it it's right there it's
right there
and so therefore we have to have legal
abortion well they're not even they're
not even pretending that anymore
now with the possible shift in the the
court
to being more conservative with the
nomination of amy coney barrett
there's a possibility i don't think it's
a very high possibility but there's a
possibility that roe v wade gets
overturned so joe biden was asked at
this town hall the other night
what will you do if it gets overturned
he said oh well
no more of this abortion should be safe
and rare abortion you know it's
constitutional even though i oppose it
he says he would make roe v wade the law
of the land
number one we don't know exactly what
she will do although expectation is that
she may very well move the overview
overview
over rule row and but the only thing the
only
responsible response to that would be to
pass legislation
making roe the law of the land that's
what i would do
that's what he would do he would make it
the law of the land
it was so interesting the way this woman
asked the question to he was asked right
just by constituents in the town hall
and when the woman wanted to ask about
abortion
obviously that was what the whole
question was about that's what biden's
whole answer is about
she couldn't bring herself to actually
use the term abortion
i knew whenever i was graduating high
school and entering college that i
wanted to
obtain my degree and start a career
before starting a family
having access to birth control and safe
reproductive health care was imperative
in making
that untrue for me so um considering the
new supreme court nomination of amy
um coney barrett what are your
particular plans to protect women's
reproductive rights in the u.s
just as a a pure matter of semantics
abortion
is not reproductive rights it's the
opposite of reproductive rights
it it does the opposite of reproduction
right there's no there's no way you can
use the term reproduction
to refer to abortion those are those are
opposite things
but she can't bring herself to say it
she can't bring herself to say it
because it's obviously such a ghastly
thing
and it's such a ghastly thing it's so
obviously wrong
that even its most ardent supporters
can't say the name abortion
abortion what is abortion even abortion
is
a clinical term killing a baby they
can't say it
even though they support it but joe
biden is taking a pretty extreme view of
it
he's saying okay look maybe it's not a
constitutional right but
i would pass a law now passing a law for
abortion i guess is more
constitutionally legitimate than just
pretending that it's in some
clause of the constitution but does joe
biden really think this is going to help
him win pennsylvania
help him win wisconsin carolina i don't
think so
i don't think it will because even
though it's about a 50 50 issue it's not
as though
the majority of americans are pro-life
but it's about 50 50.
50 50 is enough to drive a wedge between
biden and those swing state voters
and then you have the racial demagoguery
you have this racial issue
that keeps cropping up that is not
merely the wackos
ibrum candy that pseudo scholar con
artist
or the 1619 project another
pseudo-scholarly
con job you even hear michelle obama
ginning up racial tensions and the hope
that she can hold on to her voters
they're stoking
fears about black and brown americans
lying about how minorities
will destroy the suburbs whipping up
violence and intimidation and they're
pinning it
all on what's been an overwhelmingly
peaceful movement for racial solidarity
it's true research backs it up only a
tiny fraction
of demonstrations have had any violence
at all
so what the president is doing is once
again
patently false it's morally wrong
and yes it is racist
but that doesn't mean it won't work the
one thing this president
is really really good at is using fear
and confusion
and spreading lies to win blm is a
mostly peaceful movement didn't you know
that i mean they burn down
minneapolis they burn down kenosha they
burn down
atlanta they burned down dc
they burned they're burning down all of
these cities but it's only a very very
tiny fraction
of these anarchists and rioters who are
burning down these cities
the rest of them are just marching with
them as they burn down the cities
you know only a very very tiny fraction
of serbian nationalists started world
war one it's not a big deal
okay only a very very tiny fraction of
islamists
have attacked the homeland and killed
thousands of civilians a very tiny
fraction of them
so it's not a big deal right this
movement
may be fiery but it's mostly peaceful
that's michelle that's her line i guess
and she's sticking to it and it's the
same old church trump is a racist he's a
racist isn't he
he says that minorities are going to
ruin the suburbs that's not what he says
he just reversed an obama-era
bureaucratic rule
that took the rights of zoning away from
suburban communities
gave it to the federal government
completely illegitimately
and tried to move very very low income
people
from the inner cities and when i say low
income by the way i'm not talking about
the blue collar working class
i'm talking about people who are
receiving
welfare benefits who are in often gaming
the system
trying to ship them up to communities
and the communities have no say in that
at all and what was the point of that
purely political purely political
because
generally the cities are blue generally
the country is red and the suburbs are
the battleground the
suburbs are purple so if you can shift
up a lot of democratic voters
into the suburbs what happens the
suburbs all go blue that's another
example of this issue where we say look
it's not
polit this is not political this is just
the experts are saying we've got to
put the the very low income welfare
recipients
into these suburban communities that's
not like that's not politics
okay that's just common sense common
sense right seems pretty political to me
and i don't think michelle obama's
fooling anybody certainly nobody
with with common sense then you've got
the
the ace and the hole for trump in
november that is the confirmation of amy
coney barrett
who is now going to be front and center
mitch mcconnell says amy coney barrett
is going to be a huge key to the
november elections
well what's going to really help the
senate races i think are putting the
supreme court justice front and center
let the american people
take a look at her evaluate her
credentials
every single challenger to every one of
my incumbents is opposed to this nominee
every single one of them
so we'll let the american people in each
of these states that are hotly contested
decide how important the united states
supreme court is in casting
their vote november 3rd
of course of course it's going to be
very important think about what
kavanaugh did
in in the last cycle so
i think it's very smart you got to focus
on amy coney barrett part of what's
going on now
to do that is that president trump is
halting discussions
for covid19 relief and this is
being made very controversial especially
on the right what is he doing he's
losing the election you've got to send
people those free 1200
checks i don't think so i think trump is
actually totally right first of all
he tweeted out he said i'm halting the
relief talks i'm going to wait until
after the election then we're going to
get a big fat relief check
now this is very possibly a negotiating
tactic
he might very possibly be just putting
pressure on nancy pelosi here so i'm not
even sure i take that
statement at face value but even if he's
serious it's not necessarily a bad idea
washington can't do multiple things at
the same time
certainly can't do multiple big things
at the same time a covid relief package
is a pretty big deal
nancy pelosi wants 2.4 trillion i think
trump wants 1.6 trillion
never the twain shall meet the
confirmation of amy coney barrett is
going to be the biggest political
decision
in years if they try to do them both at
the same time
you are going to see some
intermingling of these negotiations i
think you're going to see some tit for
that
some kind of trade-offs here maybe the
democrats come to one of those squishy
republican senators say look
we'll give you this if we win if we do
this if you maybe change your vote on
barrett
you could see people saying okay look
we've got to delay the vote on barrett
but then i'll give you this for your
state or for your district it's going to
get
very very complicated there's no way to
predict how complicated it could get
so unless you get a clean coveted relief
bill which i think that would be fine
but unless you do that it's much more
important to focus on amy coney barrett
the political benefit
from confirming judge barrett is going
to be much greater
than maybe sending people a thousand
bucks or 1200 bucks of their own money
again
even though they probably won't get that
for some time
as a political calculation i think it's
actually pretty smart at least
at the very least to make this threat
right now
because there are people now who are
trying to claim victories today
and people who are trying to work for
victories tomorrow and some people are
giving up victories today to work for
those victories tomorrow you know
president trump we're all very happy
that he's recovered well dr fauci says
not so fast
dr fauci was on chris cuomo's show on
cnn and he comes out and he says hey
don't celebrate president trump's
recovery he could have a reversal any
day
even if he is getting better you're
going to have to keep more not you
they will have to keep monitoring him
right just to make sure there's no
residual
or secondary or long haul i mean even if
you have a quick spell with great
experimental treatment
you still got to be a little worried
there right well chris rather than
worrying about the long haul
you know we he looks fine as you can see
the way he looked
when he came out of the hospital the
issue is that he's still
early enough in the disease that it's no
secret
that if you look at the clinical course
of people sometimes when you're five to
eight days in
you're gonna have a reversal his
physicians know a reversal meaning
going in the wrong direction and getting
the trouble oh that's what a reversal it
thank you dr fatchi for clearing that up
i didn't know what the word reversal
means yeah i know of course yes oh my
gosh this guy
this guy why is he still in public life
he's been around forever
this guy he was probably the medical
advisor to george washington
he's been in that job since the 80s
that's weird why has he been in that job
so long
that's not political that's not that's
why it's not political
the elected people they're political
they come and go but fauci no he's not
political
he just uh runs a lot of our political
life but he's not political that's why
he's been there for 50 years
dr fauci says look trump is doing better
but he could get worse yeah sure we all
could i don't know we could i could get
hit by a bus tomorrow
i hope i don't god forbid but i go i
could
it doesn't mean you don't celebrate the
wins today this is something trump
understands very well
trump always takes the win
he takes the win on the stock market he
takes the win on the kanye endorsement
he takes the win on
kovid he takes the win and people say
trump you shouldn't do that
because the stock market could go down
tomorrow trump you shouldn't do that
because kanye might say something crazy
tomorrow
trump you shouldn't do that you might
get sicker tomorrow he goes yeah sure
i'll deal with that tomorrow
i am not going to give away an actual
victory today because of a possible
loss tomorrow by the way the democrats
aren't going to give me credit
for victories anyway they're going to
say that everything's a loss anyway so
who cares i'm not going to have to pay
any political consequence at all
absolutely take the win
take the victory we're going to see
tonight if we're going to get another
victory
at the vice presidential debate we do
though i have before we get into that
debate
we'll have to see what happens tonight
because the
democrats are requesting that mike pence
be enclosed in a plexiglas
box so that he doesn't infect kamala
doesn't want to get kamala sick of
course
kamala with that crazy cackle of hers i
think is much more likely to get mike
pensick
she's got all those droplets all the
time from that nervous laughter she
she goes into when she gets called out
for her lies
so pence obviously says you know i don't
think
i don't think i want to be in a
plexiglas cage for the debate i don't
think that's a good look
well it's not a political question mr
pence because the medical experts dara
cass not political
dara cass md who yes she has her
pronouns
as the first two words in her bio she
her
but she and she she has this group
called fem
nm in the em and like
emergency medicine i don't i guess
that's what that means
feminism sounds kind of like a feminist
and she has the word boss
in her bio that's nobody who's calls
themselves boss is really much of a boss
i suspect but sounds kind of feministic
but look she's not
i'm just here's what i'm saying she's
not political
and she's saying he's got to be on the
plexiglass
so let's be honest this is not only
about senator harris what she's doing is
advocating for the appropriate behavior
from the vice president for everybody at
the venue remembering that when he
enters the facility will he be wearing a
mask
when he gets on stage what happens to
the housekeeping staff the av
staff all the people in the audience the
moderator the only plex class barrier
that should be mandatory at this vice
presidential debate
should be around vice president pence
and let's be honest if he's saying i
don't care enough about those at the
facility
not just about senator harris that he's
really exemplifying what it means to be
the leader
of the covet task force i mean it's just
like it's just common sense i mean come
on
it's just we should take mike pence and
put him in a little box
and throw him down a well because you
know because he
he doesn't have this this virus that
you know statistically like
statistically 99 plus percent of people
are going to recover from he doesn't
have it but
he i don't know he like knows a guy who
had it and
i'm sure kamala harris knows people
who've had it too but that's not anyway
oh and i'm missing my point
uh it's just the appropriate behavior
the scientifically
non-political appropriate behavior is to
banish mike pence to an island in the
middle of the caribbean okay it's just
it's not politics it's just science i
think it's politics
i think we need to re-examine our
politics i think we need to
re-embrace our politics politics is not
a dirty word and the more we pretend
that it is the more politics will be
absolutely dominated by the left i'm
michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
assistant director
pavel wadowski editor and associate
producer danny d'amico
audio mixer robin fenderson hair and
makeup
nika geneva and production assistant
ryan love
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle
well tune in to the ben shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more
see you there